this is the first time you've been on
tiger belly second second yeah oh you've
done it before yeah orig the original
one we went apartment we went and saw Mr
Rogers two days before and then we did
the podcast oh that's right that was so
long ago yeah welcome back thank
you welcome back hey I remember yeah
just [__] time happy you know let's
move on look at this
Bobby oh yeah so that was back in the
old days yeah the old days amazing who's
that that's me on the right that is yeah
okay that's right that's me yeah with
that little bird's eye view camera I
remember dude look at that room look at
that room dude miss that those the early
days right early days early days of
tiger F days fun days dude it now let me
ask you guys this do you I mean what
you've grown this into is pretty special
do you look back at stuff like that and
and and are you immediately transformed
back to that time or are you so just
present moving forward click no it makes
us you know reminiscent and nostalgic
and a little you know sad about sad but
I even miss um the kind of relationship
cuz like you know like when we were a
couple we always wanted to be like let's
get the house let's get the house but we
had a ton of fun in that tiny little
condo living with all the animals like
and we were just so cramped but we I
don't know it was fun with seven animals
in that little two bedroom but now you
have space for your knicknacks I feel
like all these little statues and
figurines were were just covering that
yeah yeah pal yeah yeah yeah pal
I remember we played FIFA once that's
right and I was so bad and I that could
have been a moment where anyone looking
from the outside in being like that was
the end of their friendship because I
embarrassed you so much I think in front
of Ian Edwards or somebody did I really
did you really beat me I beat you and
you got very angry like a kid when when
you beat me the other day F oh oh my god
did I get angry cuz I was like what do
these buttons do and then I scored I
feel like in a different time you would
cuz I I beat you I've scored on you
before in the old house you would be
very upset where I but felt like he was
really like restraining the anger this
time cuz they played at the airport
before a flight cuz our flight got
delayed 5 hours a crowd formed I know
and then I wasn't there but they emerged
and I knew something was wrong I was
like oh he's not well
he's and then I find out that Gilbert
had beat him back to back no no no no it
was back to back no what are you right
it was
4-0 ooh that hurt o stop take a beat
take it in
n you can't get a n no
no NS for you dude no more no more wait
what did you think when you let me
finish this okay [__] face listen I'm
trying to be a better person yeah is I'm
trying to take the loss and you know and
accept it it was fun I I thought it was
right what so what I'm saying is what
you're doing is reigniting the [__]
Dragon but he wasn't even gloating when
it happened oh my you every gold he was
fuckingo are you your [__] M he was
stand I don't know what came over me
every time I everyone in the
building I was out of your [__] the
audience has to understand Bobby is very
good at FIFA so if you beat him it's
kind of like what the [__] is happening
right now oh my
God anyways let's go back to you you
beat me once I beat you once yeah
unexpectedly big mistake three to one or
something it was there was no chance but
in front of his friends too there were a
couple people there Ian didn't you have
like chinchillas or something yeah Ian's
good at it right is he good at it I
think so Griffin it's my favorite with
the in right now cuz Manchester United
is so bad oh they just lost right no
they won again they finally won again
wait the Arsenal beat Man City yeah yeah
we did anyway what a beautiful day have
you watched that David Beckham
documentary I got downloaded I haven't
seen it yet have you seen it no it looks
okay they're really funny Posh is so
funny really really so funny she's a
Spice Girl right they had do yeah but
also you don't know this about him but
David Beckham is like extreme OCD oh
with cleanliness and symmetry so like at
like they were like oh like why does